ถ้าหมุนลูกบอลรอบแกนหนึ่งแล้วแกนอื่น มันจะไม่เหมือนกับทำสองการหมุนในลำดับย้อนกลัน
วันนี้ใน Qiskit in the classroom เราจะเห็นว่าลูกบอลนี้มีความเกี่ยวข้องกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอย่างไร และหนึ่งในหลักการที่มีชื่อเสียงที่สุด
ในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมนั่นก็คือหลักความไม่แน่นอน
ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the classroom ซีรีส์วิดีโอที่เราอธิบายแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่คุณ
อาจเจอในหลักสูตรที่เกี่ยวกับ Quantum Computing แต่ละวิดีโอมาพร้อมกับโมดูลเชิงโต้ตอบที่ลิงก์ในคำ
อธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมไปดูกัน วันนี้เราพูดถึงหลักความไม่แน่นอน Heisenberg ถ้า
คุณเคยได้ยินมาก่อน อาจเคยได้ยินเรื่องตลกเก่าเกี่ยวกับ Heisenberg วันหนึ่งเขาถูกตำรวจดึงรถ และตำรวจถามว่า คุณ
รู้ไหมว่าคุณขับเร็วแค่ไหน Heisenberg ตอบว่า ไม่รู้ แต่ฉันรู้ว่าตัวเองอยู่ที่ไหนแน่ๆ นี่แหละคือ
หลักความไม่แน่นอน Heisenberg โดยสรุป ไม่สามารถรู้ตำแหน่งและโมเมนตัมของอนุภาคพร้อมกันได้
อย่างแม่นยำสมบูรณ์แบบ มักเขียนแบบนี้ Delta x คูณ Delta p มากกว่า
หรือเท่ากับ h หาร 2 โดย Delta X และ Delta P คือ
ความไม่แน่นอนในตำแหน่งและโมเมนตัม และ h คือค่าคงที่พื้นฐานขนาดเล็กในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
Heisenberg คิดสมการนี้ขึ้นมาในปี 1927 เมื่อเขากำลังจินตนาการถึงวิธีวัดตำแหน่งของอิเล็กตรอน ถ้า
คุณกระดอนโฟตอนออกมาเพื่อดูว่ามันอยู่ที่ไหน โฟตอนนั้นจะเตะอิเล็กตรอนอย่างหลีกเลี่ยงไม่ได้และรบกวนโมเมนตัมของมัน
นี่ไม่ใช่แค่คำกล่าวเกี่ยวกับการวัดที่รบกวนระบบ มันบอกเราว่ามีขีดจำกัดพื้นฐาน
ต่อสิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับธรรมชาติได้ นี่เป็นตัวอย่างหนึ่งของหลักการที่กว้างกว่าที่เรียกว่า complementarity ซึ่ง
บอกว่าแง่มุมบางอย่างของธรรมชาติเข้ากันไม่ได้และสังเกตไม่ได้
พร้อมกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น วัตถุควอนตัมบางครั้งประพฤติเหมือนอนุภาคและบางครั้งเหมือนคลื่น
แต่สังเกตพฤติกรรมทั้งสองพร้อมกันไม่ได้ ความสัมพันธ์ตำแหน่งและโมเมนตัมของ Heisenberg ครอบคลุมแค่หนึ่งใน
ชุดคุณสมบัติ complementary หลายชุด ความไม่แน่นอนโดยธรรมชาติเกี่ยวข้องกับวิธีที่เรามองคุณสมบัติอย่าง
ตำแหน่งและโมเมนตัมในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม แทนที่จะคิดว่า x และ p เป็นตัวแปรหรือคุณสมบัติเนื้อแท้ที่
แต่ละอนุภาคมี ในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม ตำแหน่งและโมเมนตัมคือ operator ไม่ใช่คุณสมบัติของ
ระบบ แต่เป็นสิ่งที่คุณทำกับระบบ การเรียนรู้ตำแหน่งของอนุภาคต้องการให้คุณดำเนิน
การบนระบบนั้นและทำการวัด การดำเนินการนี้อาจส่งผลต่อผลลัพธ์ของการดำเนิน
การอื่นๆ ที่ตามมา เปรียบเทียบกับไม้แห้งชิ้นหนึ่ง มันมีคุณสมบัติหลายอย่างเช่น
ตำแหน่ง ขนาด รูปร่าง มันยังมีคุณสมบัติว่าสามารถเผาไหม้ได้และลอยน้ำได้ ถ้าไม้นี้เป็น
วัตถุควอนตัม สิ่งเหล่านี้จะไม่ใช่คุณสมบัติที่คุณแค่รู้ล่วงหน้าได้ แต่กลับบอกว่ามันเป็น
observable ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่คุณเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับระบบได้ถ้าดำเนินการบางอย่างกับมัน ดังนั้นคุณต้องใช้
operator ความสามารถในการเผาไหม้หรือลอยน้ำ ซึ่งต้องลองเผาไม้จริงๆ หรือใส่ไว้ใน
น้ำเพื่อดูว่าลอยได้ไหม ตอนนี้ผลลัพธ์ของแต่ละ operator นั้นขึ้นอยู่กับลำดับที่ใช้ ถ้า
ทดสอบความสามารถในการเผาไหม้ก่อน ไม้จะไหม้กลายเป็นเถ้า และจะไม่สามารถทดสอบว่าลอยได้ไหม แต่ถ้าทดสอบ
ความสามารถลอยก่อน มันก็จะเปียกเกินกว่าจะเผาได้ เราบอกว่า operator ความสามารถในการเผาไหม้และ
ลอยน้ำไม่ commute ลำดับของการดำเนินการสำคัญมาก สิ่งนี้นำไปสู่ขีดจำกัดพื้นฐาน
ต่อการรู้จักสอง observable นี้ของไม้ได้ดีแค่ไหน เพราะเราไม่รู้แน่นอนว่ามันเผาไหม้ได้หรือลอยได้
โดยไม่รู้บริบทของการวัดนั้น แน่นอนกับไม้จริงคุณ
ตัดมันออกเป็นครึ่งและทดสอบทั้งสองคุณสมบัติพร้อมกันได้ แต่ทำแบบนั้นกับอนุภาคควอนตัมไม่ได้ การ
เปรียบกับไม้นี้เป็นแค่การเปรียบ ความไม่แน่นอนเป็นสิ่งที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์ของควอนตัม x และ p ก็ไม่ commute เช่นกัน
และคุณสมบัตินี้ของการไม่ commute คือสิ่งที่นำไปสู่หลักความไม่แน่นอน Heisenberg โดยทั่วไป operator สองตัวใดก็ตาม
ที่ไม่ commute จะมีหลักความไม่แน่นอนของตัวเอง รูปแบบทั่วไปของหลักความไม่แน่นอนสามารถ
เขียนได้แบบนี้ Delta a คูณ Delta
B มากกว่าหรือเท่ากับ
1 ส่วน 2 คูณ commutator ของ a และ b โดย
วงเล็บนี้เรียกว่า
commutator และเท่ากับความแตกต่างระหว่างการใช้ a ก่อนแล้ว
B กับการใช้ B ก่อนแล้ว a วงเล็บมุมเหล่านี้
แสดงว่าคุณกำลังหาสิ่งที่เรียกว่า expectation value ของสิ่งที่อยู่ข้างใน โดยพื้นฐานถ้าทำการวัดเดิม
หลายครั้งมาก expectation value คือค่าเฉลี่ยของการวัดทั้งหมดนั้น วันนี้เรา
จะทดสอบและยืนยันหลักความไม่แน่นอนนี้จริงๆ บน IBM quantum computer เราจะดู observable สาม
ตัวของ qubit แสดงว่า operator ของมันไม่ commute และสุดท้ายเราจะสามารถพิสูจน์ว่าหลัก
ความไม่แน่นอนใช้ได้กับ observable เหล่านี้ ก่อนอื่น ขอแวะพูดถึงวิธีที่มีประโยชน์ในการจินตนาการ quantum
state ของ qubit มันแสดงด้วยเวกเตอร์ที่ชี้ไปที่จุดบนทรงกลมที่เรียกว่า Bloch sphere ฉันพูดถึงสิ่งนี้
ในวิดีโอก่อนหน้าที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบาย แต่ขอสรุปสั้นๆ ที่นี่ด้วย นี่คือ
Bloch sphere แต่ละเวกเตอร์ถูก parameterize ด้วยสองมุม Theta และ f
state ศูนย์อยู่ที่ขั้วเหนือและ state หนึ่งอยู่ที่ขั้วใต้ และ superposition เท่ากันของ 0 กับ 1 อยู่
ที่ไหนสักแห่งตามเส้น equator โดย f เท่ากับ relative phase ระหว่างสองส่วนของ
superposition ดังนั้น state นี้จะเท่ากับ
1 หาร root 2 คูณ state 0 บวก e ยกกำลัง i phi คูณ state 1 โดย phi คือ
phase นั้น เมื่อวัด observable ของ qubit ผลลัพธ์จะเป็นหนึ่งในสองตัวเลือกที่สอดคล้องกับสอง
state ที่เป็นไปได้ของ qubit สำหรับการทดลองที่จะทำ เราจะดู observable สามตัวและ
operator ที่สอดคล้องกัน X Y และ Z เมื่อวัด observable ใดก็ได้ คุณจะได้บวกหนึ่งหรือ
ลบหนึ่ง ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับแต่ละอันที่ขึ้นอยู่กับมุมระหว่างเวกเตอร์ของ qubit บน Bloch sphere กับ
แกนวัด อย่างที่คาดไว้ Z วัดตามแกน Z X ตามแกน X
และ Y ตามแกน y ตอนนี้จำว่าเราพูดถึง observable เพราะกับ
ระบบควอนตัม เราไม่สามารถแค่รู้สิ่งต่างๆ เกี่ยวกับระบบโดยไม่วัดมัน
และแต่ละ observable มี operation ที่สอดคล้องกัน เพราะการวัดต้องการ operation มันอาจไม่ชัดเจน แต่
ปรากฏว่า operation ที่เรียกว่า operator ที่สอดคล้องกับแต่ละ observable x y และ z คือ
การหมุน Pi รอบแกนที่สอดคล้องกัน ดังนั้น X คือการหมุนรอบ X Y
รอบ Y และ Z รอบ Z ดังนั้นเพื่อดูว่า operator เหล่านี้ commute หรือไม่ เราตรวจสอบว่าการหมุน
บนทรงกลม commute ไหม ถ้า commute หลักความไม่แน่นอนจะไม่ใช้บังคับ และเราจะสามารถรู้ X Y และ Z ของ qubit
อย่างแม่นยำสมบูรณ์ ถ้าไม่ commute เราจะสามารถหาความสัมพันธ์ความไม่แน่นอนใหม่สำหรับ qubit ดู
จุดบนลูกบอลนี้เมื่อฉันหมุนรอบ X ก่อนแล้วรอบ y มันไปอยู่
ที่นี่ ตอนนี้ลองทำในลำดับย้อนกลับ ฉันหมุนรอบ Y ก่อนแล้ว
หมุนรอบ X มันไปอยู่ที่นั่น ดังนั้นพวกมันไม่ commute แน่นอน นั่นหมายความว่า
เราไม่สามารถรู้ค่า X Y และ Z ที่แน่นอนของ qubit พร้อมกันได้ จะมี
ความสัมพันธ์ความไม่แน่นอน เราจะข้ามรายละเอียดไป แต่ท้ายที่สุดเราได้ความสัมพันธ์ความไม่แน่นอนสาม
อย่าง ดังนั้นเรามี Delta x คูณ Delta Y
มากกว่าหรือเท่ากับ Z Delta y คูณ Delta Z มากกว่าหรือ
เท่ากับ X และ Delta Z คูณ Delta X มากกว่าหรือเท่ากับ
Y ดังนั้นผลคูณของความไม่แน่นอนสองอันจะมากกว่าหรือ
เท่ากับ expectation value ของ observable ตัวที่สามเสมอ มาใช้ Qiskit ดูว่า
เกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อพยายามวัดทั้ง Z และ X ของ state ศูนย์ การวัด Z ง่าย มันคือ standard basis
ของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม การวัดเป็น Z โดยค่าเริ่มต้นเสมอ แต่เพื่อวัด X ต้องทำสิ่งที่เรียกว่า
basis change โดยพื้นฐานหมุน Bloch sphere เพื่อให้ X ชี้ขึ้นที่ Z เคยชี้ เพื่อทำสิ่งนี้
เราใช้ Hadamard gate ดังนั้น quantum circuit เต็มจะมีลักษณะแบบนี้ เราวัดใน Z ใช้ Hadamard
แล้ววัดใน X ถ้าใช้ Qiskit primitive sampler รันการทดลองหลายครั้ง เราได้
histogram ของผลลัพธ์การวัดที่มีลักษณะแบบนี้สำหรับการวัด Z
และแบบนี้สำหรับการวัดใน X ดังนั้นอย่างที่เห็น เรา
วัด qubit อยู่ใน state ศูนย์ตาม Z ด้วยความแน่ใจใกล้ 100% แต่
ตาม X เราแทบไม่รู้อะไรเกี่ยวกับ state ของ qubit เลย มันถูกวัดว่าเป็นศูนย์หรือหนึ่งด้วยโอกาส
เท่ากัน ความไม่แน่นอนใน X จึงใหญ่เกือบเท่าที่เป็นไปได้ ทำให้เรา
รู้สึกถึงการแลกเปลี่ยนของความไม่แน่นอนนี้แล้ว แต่เราทำได้ดีกว่านั้นนิดหน่อยบน quantum computer เราใช้
Qiskit primitive ที่เรียกว่า estimator เพื่อหา expectation value ของ observable X Y และ Z และ
ความไม่แน่นอนในแต่ละตัว มาลองทำสำหรับ state ที่ชี้ไปทิศบวก X บน Bloch sphere เราจะใช้ estimator
เพื่อคำนวณความไม่แน่นอนใน x และ z สำหรับ state นี้และ expectation value ของ
y ด้วย state นี้เราได้ผลลัพธ์นี้จาก Qiskit เมื่อเราหาผลคูณของสอง
ความไม่แน่นอนใน X และ Y เราเห็นว่าตามที่คาดไว้มันใหญ่กว่า absolute
value ของ expectation value ของ y แต่นี่เป็นแค่สำหรับ state เดียว เราต้องการให้แน่ใจว่าสมการนี้
ใช้ได้กับทุก qubit state มาใช้ estimator อีกครั้ง แต่คราวนี้ให้มันสแกนค่าของ
parameter และหา expectation value ที่ทุกค่า parameter ที่ให้ ตรงนี้ parameter ที่ต้องการ
สแกนคือมุม Theta บน Bloch sphere เพื่อตรวจสอบสมการสำหรับ qubit state ทั้งหมดที่อยู่บน
arc ที่ตัด XZ plane เมื่อทำสิ่งนี้เราได้กราฟเป็นฟังก์ชันของมุม Theta เส้นสี
แดงคือผลคูณของสองความไม่แน่นอน และเส้นสีส้มคือ expectation value ของ y ตามที่คาดไว้
ผลคูณของความไม่แน่นอนใน x และ z สูงกว่า expectation value ของ y มาก แต่นั่น
ไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะตอบสนองสมการ เพราะ expectation value ของ y ต่ำมาก มันเป็นศูนย์สำหรับทุก state บน
arc นี้ มาทำ scan คล้ายกันผ่านค่า Theta แต่แทนที่จะ scan ใน XZ plane เราจะให้ phi เท่ากับ pi หาร
4 ดังนั้นเราดู qubit state ที่อยู่บน arc ต่างกันบนทรงกลม ตรงนี้เราเห็นว่าสมการ
ถูกทดสอบมากขึ้นนิดหน่อย เพราะเส้นสีส้มและเส้นสีแดงอยู่ใกล้กันกว่า แต่เส้นแดงอยู่เหนือเส้นส้มเสมอ
และหลักความไม่แน่นอนยังคงใช้ได้ เรายังไม่ได้ตรวจสอบทุก state แต่หวังว่าคุณเริ่มเข้าใจ
ความคิดนี้แล้ว มีความไม่รู้พื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับสองแง่มุม complementary ของระบบควอนตัม
รวมถึง qubit นี้ที่เราใช้อยู่ หลักความไม่แน่นอนบังคับให้เราเผชิญกับความจริงว่าไม่ว่า
พยายามแค่ไหน ไม่ว่าการวัดของเราจะฉลาดแค่ไหน เราจะไม่มีทางรู้ทุกอย่างอย่างแม่นยำสมบูรณ์แบบได้
ไม่มีทางหลีกเลี่ยงได้เลย ถ้าไม่เชื่อฉัน หรือแม้แต่เชื่อก็ตาม ฉันท้าให้คุณไปดูโมดูล
ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบาย และลองเอาชนะหลักความไม่แน่นอนดู ขอบคุณที่รับชม แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า